displaced by serious War people living
in this makeshift camp in idlib Province
are again left homeless it was early
Sunday morning when government forces
launched their first round of attacks
blood stains on the floor now Mark where
many tried to take cover without any
luck
when we first heard the explosions we
thought it was happening somewhere else
children ran out of a tents scared they
started shouting Rockets Rockets we
didn't know where to go all we could
hear were bombs it wasn't one or two it
felt like 100.
at least nine people were killed among
them children
Hospital a medical team tries to save
the lives of young patients
we're treating three children who are
under the age of five they have serious
injuries we had to transfer others to
the Intensive Care Unit due to nerve
damage
the attack on rebel-held areas marks yet
another violation of a 2020 truce in
idlib province
the region is the last pocket of armed
resistance against President Bashar
al-assad
and the shelling reportedly comes a day
after pro-government forces were killed
in a separate attack
this is how opposition Fighters
responded the civil war that broke out
in 2011 may be over but fighting still
erupts between government forces and
Rebels
and now this recent escalation is
fueling concerns that more attacks will
follow
Katya Lopez Al Jazeera